[Music]
Luise son me now Julius today produces
so forth bringing one of the great
stones to Stonehenge is itself a
religious ritual for these ancient
Britons when we build big monuments
today
the stone is collected it's just a
commodity it's just a bit of useful rock
that we buy off somebody and someone
brings it along and puts it up I think
we're looking at something completely
different at this time because the rocks
are imbued with meaning and maybe even
with soul and spirit the closest source
of the large sarsen stones is here at
the Marlborough downs to the north of
Stonehenge bringing a sarsen stone to
Stonehenge requires years of planning
roots must be chosen and prepared stones
carefully selected
for the group the journey means
considerable hardship they must abandon
their farms and take to a nomadic life
[Music]
these Stone Age people have only the
simplest of tools and materials to pull
a 45-ton stone to Stonehenge they have
to make every item they will need for
the difficult journey to haul the stone
they weave long lengths of rope made
from thin strips of bark soaked in water
they place logs underneath to raise the
stone up this will allow them to
construct a wooden cradle onto which
they can fix runners and attach ropes
for pulling now it should be easier to
overcome the friction stopping the stone
from moving
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the beginning of a long and
dangerous journey they hope to honor the
ancestors by bringing a stone to
Stonehenge but they also fear their
retribution if they fail it seems odd
for us perhaps to think of ancestors as
being a key religious concept but we're
talking about early farmers who are
deriving their living from nature and in
societies like this it's very common in
many parts of the world for ancestors to
be the source of all of these blessings
so that if the ancestors are upset then
maybe they will actually withhold the
bounties of nature
it is not only the possible wrath of the
ancestors they will have to face they
will also have to overcome many
obstacles about their duty to the Dead
is paramount they will let nothing stand
in their way
[Music]